let's go to the US now and the governor
of New York State Andrew Cuomo has been
delivering his daily briefing in the
news as distressing he said that they
recorded the highest single day increase
in deaths since the outbreak began 731
people died that is the largest
single-day
increase and we talk about numbers but
that's 731 people who we lost behind
every one of those numbers is an
individual as a family as a mother as a
father as a sister as a brother so a lot
of pain again today for many New Yorkers
and they're in our thoughts and prayers
salumi joins us now from New York
Kristin the numbers are still going in
the wrong direction in New York
that's right certainly in terms of
fatalities although in terms of
hospitalizations while they're still
going up the governor did suggest they
may be plateauing and that is a little
bit of good news he pointed out that in
1918 the Spanish flu epidemic took six
months to reach its apex whereas this
would be happening in just over a month
here in New York and in their
surrounding communities possibly of
Connecticut and New Jersey but he did
caution that extreme measures would have
to remain in place in order for that to
happen and in terms of social distancing
and he also pointed out that a
resurgence could still be possible if
hospitals weren't able to stay on top of
the situation as well there's still
concerns about gear for medical workers
beds for patients and equipment and
protective equipment as well and as well
as a number of medical personnel in
terms of beds there's been some good
news and that the us comfort which was
sent to New York to take overflow
hospital patients is now being used to
treat Kovac patients and will be able to
accept another 500 kovin patients so
was a step in the right direction
towards alleviating that problem anyway
What did he say about how much longer
what the outlook what the outlook is
pardon me Kristin for the need for
social distancing to continue and and
self-quarantine and things of a such
that's the question that everyone is
asking and he says that it's something
that he's working on with the governors
of those neighboring states one thing
that will be necessary
in order to return to life as somewhat
normal he says is more testing to find
out who's had the disease who's immune
to the disease and who can safely go
back to work and on that front New York
has approved a new antibody test for use
in the state however and that needs to
be scaled up so that it can be given to
people on a large basis he says that
that's something that they're working on
in order to get things back to normal
but right now things are closed in New
York for at least until the end of April
the measures that were announced in
terms of schools being closed and
essential businesses right now they are
affected so at least the end of April
first person this is taking quite a toll
on on health care workers physically and
mentally I think that's safe to say this
is something that the few of them have
ever experienced before what is being
done to get them help to get them
reinforcements yeah that's a real
concern because this is really intense
what they're dealing with and the
emergency rooms are certainly the
frontline not only doctors and nurses
but EMTs and police officers are getting
sick while trying to keep the rest of us
safe so there have been calls for
volunteers around the country tens of
thousands have answered that call but
here in the city the mayor has warned
that they're going to need even more
medical personnel in order to keep on
top of the situation I talked to some
volunteers who were stepping up recently
here's what they had to say